military commander General Cavalli
briefed allies
and the Polish Ambassador updated us on
the instant and the ongoing
investigation
yesterday's explosion took place as
Russia launched a massive wave of Rocket
attacks across Ukraine
since the start of Russia's illegal war
in Ukraine
NATO has increased vigilance across our
Eastern flank
and we are monitoring the situation on
continuous basis
and
investigation into this incident is
ongoing
and we need to await its outcome
but we have no indication that this was
the result of a deliberate attack
and you have no indication that Russia
is preparing offensive military actions
against NATO
our preliminary analysis
suggests that the incident was likely
caused by a Ukrainian air defense
missile fired to defend Ukrainian
territory against Russian cruise missile
attacks
but let me be clear
this is not Ukraine's fault
Russia Bears ultimate responsibility as
it continues its illegal war against
Ukraine
in the meeting today NATO allies offered
the deepest condolences on the tragic
loss of life
they expressed their strong sovereignty
with our valued Allied Poland
and made clear that we will continue to
support Ukraine in its right to
self-defense
Russia must stop this senseless War
last night I spoke with the Polish
president Andre Duda and with president
U.S President Joe Biden
we agreed that we need to stay vigilant
calm and closely coordinated
we will continue to consult and monitor
the situation very closely
NATO stands United and we will always do
what is necessary to protect and defend
all allies
and with that I'm ready to take your
questions we start with Polish radio
lady in gray at the back
Secretary General what could be the
outcome in concrete terms of today's
meeting can we expect enhancing the
Europe's air defense especially in the
country's bordering Ukraine because as
long as As the World continues there
will be Russian Rockets striking
Ukrainian cities and there is a risk
that such situation can happen again
thank you very much so in the meeting
today NATO allies expressed their strong
support so that with our Ally Poland
they also expressed the deepest
condolences for the tragic loss of life
and NATO has significantly increased its
presence in the eastern part of lions in
particular since the invasion of Ukraine
in February with more
troops
online ground troops but also with a
significant substantial troll air and
Naval power and this has of course both
increased our air defense capabilities
but also our capabilities to monitor to
to to to to to
um to have a full picture of what's
going on on the border uh between uh
NATO allies like Poland and Ukraine and
we are constantly assessing what more we
need to do we also have made important
decisions at our Summit in Madrid to
further strengthen our presence in the
eastern part of the alliance
BBC
thank you Jessica Parker from BBC News I
just wanted to ask given the incident
that happened last night do you think
this was perhaps the most tense moment
for nato in this conflict so far thank
you
I'm always careful to rank different
incidents and and situations it
demonstrates that the the war in Ukraine
which is President Putin's
responsibility
continues to create dangerous situations
at the same time we have to remember
that this happened
at the same time as Russia launched a
wave of new indiscriminate missile and
air attacks on Ukrainian cities
attacking a critical civilian
infrastructure hitting civilian targets
then it's a nothing strange then then of
course that is in itself a very
dangerous situation and then that we
then also see that
there may be also consequences on NATO
territory it's a consequence of the war
that Russia wages against Ukraine
okay we'll go to the Ukrainian news
agency in the middle yeah
thank you for foreign national news
agency of Ukraine I just want to mention
that ukrainians do understand the pain
of the Polish people and they have a
greater sympathy with them my question
is how that incident will be reflected
on the assistance that allies provided
for Ukraine in air defense where we'll
be some kind of new systems to cover the
Ukrainian Sky thanks
there will be a meeting today uh in the
contact group for Ukraine to coordinate
the support NATO allies and partners and
others are providing to Ukraine and the
main focus of our efforts over the last
months has been on air defense
especially since Russia started to
launch this indiscriminate attacks on
Ukrainian cities a few weeks ago and I
welcome that more and more allies and
partners are providing Advanced Air
Defense systems to Ukraine
nasam's Hawk batteries from from Spain
and and others and also know that Sweden
has made a new announcements of uh of uh
additional Support also with air
defenses to to Ukraine so we are
mobilizing additional support
especially when it comes to different
types of air defenses NATO is also
providing counter drones systems we need
many different systems to protect
against cruise missiles ballistic
missiles but also drones and we need a
layered defense
of of Ukraine that's exactly what the
Allies are providing in different ways
it's incident will this for more air
defense for allies on the eastern border
I know you said they've there has been a
step up since the beginning of the war
but does more need to be done thank you
so we are constantly assessing uh uh uh
our presence in the eastern part of the
alliance we have significantly increased
our presence online at Sea and in the
air and that has significantly increased
our air defense capabilities especially
in the eastern part of the alliance
at the same time we have no indication
that this incident was a result of a
deliberate attack
on NATO territory and we have no uh
indications that Russia is planning uh
offensive military actions against
NATO allies
so I think this demonstrates the dangers
connected to the ongoing war in Ukraine
but it hasn't changed our fundamental
assessment of the threat against NATO
allies it shows the importance of
monitoring or being vigilant of the
presence and we made decisions for
long-term adaptation of NATO's
deterrence and events at The Summit in
Madrid in June and that includes
partly more presence in the East partly
more pre-positioned equipment in
particular in the eastern part of the
alliance and partly earmarked forces so
we can quickly scale up the battle
groups we have in the eastern part of
the Alliance and of course all of this
was also further strengthen our air
defense capabilities then air defense is
partly land-based but air defense is
also very often
air based also aircraft and and a naval
based based on our ships and of course
Air Forces and Naval forces is something
we very quickly can move in soccer has
our Supreme Allied Commander in Europe
has already authorities to move in
additional forces including air and
Naval forces to augment our air defenses
quickly if needed
foreign
Secretary General a few factual
questions if I may
um first of all the debris found near
the border of Poland and Ukraine is this
debris only from an Ukrainian rocket
launched to intercept a Russian missile
or is there also debris of a Russian
missile and secondly what is what was
the likely trajectory of the Russian
missile that was meant to intercept by
Ukraine and thirdly did NATO forces
present at the Eastern flank activate
their air defense
systems yesterday because they saw an
incoming
potentially incoming missile thank you
so we have air defense systems in place
that are active uh 24 7 all the time we
have uh I ever explains we have a
aircraft we have uh we have land-based
systems and we have a naval base systems
so we have air defenses
which operates constantly throughout the
alliance then of course we have a
significant focus and we have in
particular increased our presence in the
eastern part of the alliance and this
also includes a pollen then on the
details of the findings and the ongoing
in investigation it will not be right if
I go into to those details but as I said
our preliminary
findings are that all that uh this is
likely caused by a Ukrainian air defense
missile and and we have no indication
that it wasn't a deliberate attack on
NATO territory
political
so if you're just joining us it is
almost midday uh that's Jen salterberg
NATO Secretary General he's been talking
of Brussels about what happened last
night on the Polish Ukrainian border
saying that there is no indication it
was a result of a deliberate attack from
Russia most likely he said a Ukrainian
air missile defense
missile that came down but he'd added
that Russia does bear ultimate
responsibility as a result of its
illegal war on Ukraine also said that he
had spoken with the Polish leader Duda
and also Joe Biden and that he says we
agreed we need to remain Vigilant calm
and closely coordinated let's bring in
Ed Arnold who is with me here
um
in terms of what he said very much
dialing down the rhetoric absolutely
very calm it's actually what the
Secretary General is is known for within
NATO have been very calm and collected
and just putting out the facts as they
see it was clear that this was not a
deliberate attack had
in Poland yesterday that we reaffirm our
solidarity with Poland we express our
condolences with the victims and we're
working with our